on
[Musique]
non
prévenir vaut mieux que guérir
une phrase souvent utilisé dans
multiples contextes mais dans le
contexte de la santé publique et le
puisque vrai vous savez les
interventions de santé publique qui aura
toujours le plus sauvé deux vies
c'est tout simplement le lavage des
mains avec le savon des vaccinations et
d'autres mesures d'assainissement de
base depuis mon bas âge j'avais dit à
mes parents comme avait mis au monde
pour améliorer la santé et en afrique
particulièrement j'en étais convaincu
à cet effet je pensais devenir médecin
est donc plein d'enthousiasmé de ces
partis voir des tampons aidé et anti
médecins africains pour leur demander
leur avis sur mon idée de devenir
médecin moi aussi à ma grande surprise
ils n'étaient pas aussi enthousiastes
comme moi ils m'ont d'abord demandé pour
pratiquer où exactement
je leur ai dit en afrique et au mali
spécifiquement et là ils m'ont regardé
et m'ont dit tu sais ma fille
la médecine en afrique est très
difficile malheureusement la majorité
des personnes en afrique ne viennent pas
consulté un médecin un temps souvent ils
s'auto mehdi qui vont voir des
traditionalistes et vient de voir le
médecin qu'en dernier recours
nous sommes souvent obligés d'envoyer le
patient chez lui sans pouvoir le guérir
concentre toi plutôt sur la santé
publique
c'est une discipline qui te permettra de
développer des projets pour la
prévention de la maladie à grande
échelle et c'est ça qui nous font en
afrique et donc j'ai écouté leurs
conseils et je me suis spécialisé dans
l'épidémiologie des maladies
infectieuses qui veut dire tout
simplement l'investigation des causes
des maladies
après plus de quinze ans de pratique en
afrique malheureusement réalise que
beaucoup de nos comportements sont la
cause de nos mains
10 prenons le palu par exemple c'est une
maladie transmise par le moustique et
qui tuent à peu près six cent vingt
mille personnes par an en afrique
particulièrement
il est vrai que pour éliminer le palu
dans un pays il faut un système
sanitaire robuste avec la capacité de
diagnostiquer traiter les cas rapidement
et une surveillance continue de la
maladie mais ya quand même des aspects
environnementaux auxquels nous pouvons
jour un produit l'habitat du moustique
ce sont les eaux stagnantes donc au mali
le seul avantage de la période sèche et
chaude c'est qu'il ya moins de
moustiques et donc moins de paludisme
mais si nous mêmes dans notre proximité
ou des personnes aux eaux sales dans la
rue ou bien le push en aucun niveau avec
nos or dieu empêchant l'eau de couler
c'est pas seulement que nous dérangeons
le voisin mais c'est que nous créons des
environnements favorables pour le
moustique et d'autres vecteurs de
maladies telles que les rats les études
démontrent que quand les communautés
s'investissent activement dans le
contrôle du paludisme
les interventions de prévention
fonctionne mieux
cela veut dire que nous avons notre
responsabilité pour garder un
environnement propre et sec et si nous
avons les symptômes du palu rendant
l'eau vite chez le médecin demandant un
diagnostic de laboratoire pour s'assurer
que c'est au fait le palu et prénom le
traitement prescrit par le médecin et
cela jusqu'au bout même si nous nous
sentons mieux avant la fin du traitement
prévenir vaut mieux que guérir
vous vous souvenez de la période des
polars en afrique de l'ouest il ya
quelques années à peu près onze mille
trois cents personnes sont mortes en
guinée en sierra leone au liberia ebola
est une maladie affreuse caractérisée
par des forte fièvre des douleurs
musculaires des vomissements des
diarrhées
des insuffisances rénales et hépatiques
et finalement par des hémorragies
internes et externes de virus d'ebola
est un des agents pathogènes les plus
contagieux et les plus foudroyant au
monde
il n'y a pas de traitement la manière
qu'on ne peut arrêter l'avancée des
mollahs en afrique de l'ouest
c'était en instaurant des mesures de
prévention telles que le lavage des
mains réduire le contact humain et une
détection rapide de l'infection des cas
suspects et des contacts
les communautés étaient fortement
impliquées et il ya eu des grandes
campagnes de sensibilisation auquel nous
avons tous adhéré c'est la prévention
qui arrêter l'avancée des polars en
afrique de l'ouest et dans le cas de vol
a malheureusement prévenir vaut mieux
que mourir
nous faisons face à une situation de
santé publique qui est très grave et
c'est la résistance aux antimicrobiens
qui veut dire qu'en des micro organismes
tels que les bactéries les virus les
parent cité les champignons se modifie
en telle sorte que les médicaments
contre les infections causées par ces
micro organismes ne sont plus efficaces
d'ici l'année 2050
nous estimons à peu près 10 millions de
décès causés par cette résistance aux
antimicrobiens 10 millions qui
représentent à peu près deux tiers de la
population entière du mali actuel
c'était long une chose que nous nous
faisons qui accélère cette résistance
aux antimicrobiens c'est l'auto
médication prendre des médicaments sans
avis médical
combien de fois avez vous tout
simplement pris les restants de
médicaments quand vous avez prescrit
dans le passé où vous êtes allés
directement chez le pharmacien pour
demander des antibiotiques etc amant
antipaludique sans avoir consulté un
médecin et obtenu un diagnostic de
laboratoire
ben vous n'êtes pas les seuls
malheureusement
figurez vous que c'est tellement courant
est particulièrement en afrique où les
facile d'obtenir des médicaments sans
ordonnance que nous avons nous même créé
une situation où certains médicaments ne
seront plus efficace contre les
infections simple et désinfection qu'on
avait vaincu dans le passé nous tuerons
a souvent à nouveau très souvent quand
nous sommes grippé ou en rue mais nous
pensons comprenant des antibiotiques ça
pourrait nous aider
ben c'est faux la grippe est causée par
un virus
notre les antibiotiques ne sont pas du
tout efficace contre les symptômes de la
grippe
les antibiotiques c'est contre les
bactéries et c'est la même histoire avec
la fiève souvent dans le pays
le patient et parfois même le médecin se
basent tout simplement sur le symptôme
d'une forte fièvre pour prendre ou
prescrire les médicaments contre le palu
quand il ya en fait beaucoup de maladies
autre que le palu qui cause ces mêmes
symptômes
il faut consulter un médecin et obtenir
un diagnostic de laboratoire pour être
sûr de quelle est la cause de vos
symptômes
ce sont des comportements semblables qui
accélère la résistance aux
antimicrobiens et aujourd'hui des
maladies telles que la tuberculose le
palu a pris place no money je veux vous
donner l'exemple de la chloroquine c'est
un médicament qui était très efficace
auparavant contre le palu le parasite
faisant le palu le plus répandu a
développé une résistance à la closerie
et du coup la chloroquine était plus
efficace
le résultat ça a été une augmentation de
la mentalité duo pas lui qu'on le trouve
d'autres médicaments
c'est ça la résistance aux
antimicrobiens ne vous auto medic et pas
si vous êtes malade consulter un médecin
obtenez un diagnostic de laboratoire et
sachez qu'elle est la vraie cause de
votre maladie pour qu'on vous donne un
traitement approprié et efficace
prévenir vaut mieux que guérir mon
souhait pour une pride africa in afrique
priante c'est une espérance de vie
élevée pour tous le pays qu'on ne parle
plus d'excision féminine ou d'autres
comportements semblables qui nous font
que du mal qu'une femme puisse accoucher
même dans le village sans avoir peur de
mouiller qu'on ne songe pas à faire
plusieurs enfants l'espérons qu'un
vivent au delà des sept premières années
et que les maladies infectieuses
évitables ne soit plus la première cause
de mortalité dans le pays et qu'un jour
un petit garçon une petite fille tout
enthousiaste vient me voir pour me dire
tu antilles j'aimerais un jour devenir
médecin en afrique et que je puisse lui
dire
vas-y
sans hésiter parce que la majorité des
personnes en afrique consultent un
médecin à temps et les centres les
services de santé de base soit de
qualité et accessible à tous c'est ça
mon combat de tous les jours sans la
sentiers santé oms n'a rien du tout
adoptant une mentalité de prévention
parce que prévenir c'est notre avenir
[Applaudissements]